Israel has summoned Australia's
Ambassador after Canberra reversed its
decision to recognize West Jerusalem as
the Israeli Capital the Australian
foreign minister says the city's status
must be decided through peace talks
between Israelis and Palestinians
Australia initially made the recognition
under former prime minister Scott
Morrison in 2018.
we will not waver in our support of
those Israel and the Jewish community in
Australia we are equally unwavering our
support of the Palestinian people
including in the provision of
humanitarian support I would say that Mr
Morrison's decision to play politics and
it was no more than that because of
course we all know where the embassy
remained resulted in Australia's
shifting position I know that this has
caused conflict and distress and concern
in parts of the Australian community and
today the government seeks to resolve
that Sarah Clarke is in Brisbane with
more
well this was an election promise that
was made by the opposition during the
election campaign of course uh the
federal government now the newly elected
Anthony Albanese government has
confirmed uh that the government would
no longer recognize West Jerusalem as
the Israeli Capital now on Monday
evening interestingly enough the foreign
minister Penny Wong was denying uh this
was the case and that was simply because
it was ahead of the cabinet meeting
which happened on Tuesday cabinet has
now given it the all clear now in a
press conference in Australia the
foreign minister Penny Wong said that
Australia is committed to a two-state
solution in which Israel and a future
Palestinian state would co-exist she
said this will be done in peace and
security and with internationally
recognized borders she also noted and
having a bit of a hit at the former
government in particular the former
prime minister Scott Morrison that they
would not support his position or any
approach that undermine their current
policy so in the press conference she
also noted that the final status of the
capital should not be determined until
peace negotiations with the Palestinians
were finalized pennywong was also quick
to clarify and note her support for the
Israel and the Jewish Community she said
that they have the government under
Anthony albanesi has equally unwavering
supporters of the Palestinian people
Wong described the decision by Scott
Morrison back in 2018 as cynical risky
and a political decision one to try and
win over voters in a key seat a key Blue
Ribbon seat known as Wentworth ahead of
last year's election now should also
note that Malaysia was highly critical
of Scott Morrison's decision at the time
back in 2018 he described it as a
humiliation of the Palestinian people
and their quest for a Homeland but of
course and not surprisingly Donald Trump
he applauded us and said it's a step in
the right direction and a recognition of
reality so it can confirm in Australia
now after a cabinet meeting I'm not a
surprise but the reversal of a decision
made by the previous government that the
federal government would no longer
recognize West Jerusalem as the Israeli
capital
and live now to West Jerusalem and
Bernard Smith Bernard the Israelis is
not happy at all with this Australian
decision
no Foley they're not the Australia
Israel's foreign minister has voiced its
deep disappointment over the decision
and prime minister yah lakhpeed who's
running for uh re-election in the
beginning of November he says he can
only hope the Australian government
matters manages other matters more
seriously and professionally relating to
the manner in which this announcement by
the Australians were made now the
Israelis have summoned the Australian
Ambassador but he'll have to drive all
the way from Tel Aviv to Jerusalem
because while Australia recognized West
Jerusalem as well recognized Jerusalem
as the capital of Israel they never
actually physically moved their Embassy
like almost every other country their
Embassy building and administration is
in Tel Aviv it's only the U.S embassy
that's here in Israel after Donald Trump
recognized Jerusalem in 2018 and also
Honduras and Guatemala so practically
little changes but of course it's all in
the symbolism other countries most
countries recognize that the status the
final status of Jerusalem is to be
determined in talks on Palestinian
statehood and the Palestinians want East
Jerusalem as their Capital it's where
most of the Christian Muslim and Jewish
holy sites happen to be as well but they
want the final status of Jerusalem up
for negotiation and what's been the
Palestinian reaction
well the Palestinian foreign minister
Riedel Maliki the Palestinian
authorities foreign minister he's called
this a correction of a mistake made by a
previous government and he now also
wants Australia to go on and recognize
the Palestinian State he says if
Australia is interested in a two-state
solution then recognize us as an
independent state as other countries
have done the Palestinians while there's
been no realistic talks on Palestinian
statehood since about 2014 when the last
lot of us brokered talks ended up they
still hold out and recognize and want
East Jerusalem as their future Capital
practically these are two this Jerusalem
is divided between the Palestinian East
and the Jewish West both sides you
rarely see but one Crossing from one
side to the other so this remains a
divided City and the Palestinians want
that Eastern side as their future
capital thank you for that Bernard Smith
live there in Western Muslim